Sonic the Hedgehog is a family-friendly
movie but there are a few things in it
that'll leave older viewers scratching
their heads much like Sonic himself the
movie zips by pretty quickly here are
the things we saw that only adults would
have noticed
Tom wachowski by all measures is a good
person sure he's a police officer who
breaks the law and ends up being hunted
by the public as a terrorist but he does
it all to save his new friend Sonic that
apparent selflessness doesn't stop
Rachel the sister of Tom's wife Maddie
from eating everything about him of
course Tom eventually becomes a fugitive
and Rachel gets tied up for good measure
finally giving her a clear reason to
dislike Tom but Rachel wasn't a fan long
before all that Rachel even goes as far
as suggesting Tom and Maddie get a
divorce maybe Tom did something off
screen or in a deleted scene but from
what we can tell he's a good husband
loves his wife wants to save people and
appears to be the most helpful person in
Green Hills Rachel and Maddie also
seemed to have a good relationship
making Rachel's hate for Tom even more
unjustified it's all about family Tom
dr. evil Eggman Robotnik wants to catch
sonic so he can study the
extraterrestrial blue hedgehog and his
powers however this plan is misguided
from the beginning as dr. Robotnik
consistently shoots to kill when dr.
Robotnik and Sonic first meet at Tom's
house Robotnik sends his mad scientist
drones after sonic guns blazing it's
hard not to wonder why someone who wants
to study a being would try to kill it
first dead or alive is a common phrase
bad guys use in movies but in this case
it's more beneficial for dr. Robotnik to
keep Sonic alive later in the movie dr.
Robotnik discovers one of Sonic's quills
studies its powers and uses the quill to
make his ship and drone army stronger
clearly there are benefits to not
shooting first and asking questions
later
for a guy who's supposed to be the
smartest asset at the US military's
disposal Robotnik is awfully slow on the
uptake I'm sorry major what was your
name nobody cares
during Sonic the Hedgehog Tom doesn't
just become a wanted fugitive he's
deemed a full-blown dangerous terrorist
yet when dr. Robotnik magically
disappears
apparently able to go right back to his
normal life Greenhills clearly isn't a
major city which would seem to make it
incredibly difficult for Tom to even
show his face outside the house but once
the government decides all's well that
ends well this fellow citizens seem to
agree even if Tom were somehow able to
offer the entire world proof of his
innocence
there's no way life would return to
normal that quickly in the real world
people tend to attach negative
connotations to those accused of major
crimes whether or not they're eventually
convicted Tom's career in law
enforcement would seem to be yet another
complicating factor what kind of
small-town cop would get to go back on
patrol right after getting himself mixed
up in something like this what am I
Sonic the Hedgehog is a fairly
lighthearted movie but there's no
getting around the fact that Sonic
himself causes a lot of destruction his
baserunning shenanigans caused the
widespread power outage that sets the
events of the movie's plot in motion as
a result businesses and residents lose
their power and the government in
military have to step in those types of
resources cost a lot of money while it's
dr. Robotnik's fault first shooting up
the streets with his drones and ship
none of it would have happened if Sonic
hadn't been rather careless with his
powers in the first place it's
entertaining to watch Sonic dodge the
mustache wearing dr. Robotnik but for
the adults in the audience it starred
not to wonder who's going to pay for all
the cleanup and repair when it's all
over Sonic is cool lives on his own
terms is a bit edgy and partly corny in
short he's a big-screen character
created with the cultural template of a
Jen's ear of course he's still a blue
hedgehog who shouldn't really have any
interest in or reference point to pop
culture but the filmmakers had a vested
interest in making Sonic as relatable as
possible to the audience while being
funny for the whole family what better
way to make sure he can relate to the
kids in the crowd of course Millennials
are also part of the target demographic
since the first Sonic video game was
released in 1991 Sonic's dear friend Tom
is more culturally in line with older
audience members even though everyone
can appreciate a good dad joke Sonic's
unintentional show of power and the
massive power outage that resulted led
to the government and military stepping
in and hiring the clearly insane dr.
Robotnik to figure out what happen
although Sonic the Hedgehog is meant to
be a light-hearted movie that the entire
family can enjoy if an extraterrestrial
blue hedgehog suddenly appeared in real
life and seemed to pose some sort of
threat every branch of the military
would be involved there's no way the
government would trust a single mad
scientist to do the job everybody Jim
Carrey's mugging scene stealing antics
are one of the best parts of the movie
but they also might be the most
unbelievable given that this is about a
super-fast
alien Hedgehog who can talk that's
really saying something dr. Robotnik is
the type of person who has to state his
accomplishments out loud even when no
one's asking he's clearly an
accomplished individual so much so that
the government tasks him with
determining why the lights went out
through this behavior it's clear that he
has to prove he's better than everyone
else
and he points out the shortcomings of
others simply because they took a
different path this is because people
like dr. Robotnik are insecure possibly
because he had a painful childhood he
mentions to Tom that the only other
person who punched him in the face was a
bully when he was younger which may have
led to him being the way he is on the
surface he's an accomplished villain who
makes the audience laugh with a touch of
Jim Carrey goofiness and quirks but deep
down he's insecure and deals with his
insecurities by cutting others down or
blasting them to bits with his drone
army while the government rewarding tom
with a $50 Olive Garden gift card is
meant to be funny it's also an
absolutely terrible way to say thanks
for saving the world most sane adults
wouldn't be content with receiving any
kind of gift card at any amount for what
Tom and his family went through the
government at the very least should be
concerned about dr. Robotnik their main
asset what happened is a big deal and
deserves answers yet the world seems
content with simply forgetting anything
ever happens and moving on Sonic and the
Wachowskis deserve a happy ending it's a
sweet funny way of concluding this
feel-good tale but for anyone with a job
and a mortgage Sonic the Hedgehog's
conclusion will make absolutely no sense
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a thing
one
[Applause]